former nevada nevada assemblyman stephen  brooks is once again in trouble with the  law brooks is facing a charge of felon  in possession of a firearm  after a gun was fired during a fight at  his house  another man richard gaines faces three  charges of assault with a deadly weapon  and firing into a vehicle police say  gaines shot at another car  after it was leaving an arrest report  says when searching the home  officers found a shotgun brooks was not  allowed to have  because of previous felony convictions  their next court date is scheduled for  may  brooks by the way is the only lawmaker  to ever be expelled by the legislature  in 2011  after members of the legislature said  his actions made them feel  unsafe brooks then led california police  on a high-speed chase here and  hit a police dog with a wrench he served  some jail time in california  and he's been arrested a few times in  las vegas since then